Kylie Jenner sparks engagement rumors
amazing as sister Kim Kardashian
celebrates her third baby shower okay
guys my baby shower for baby number
three I love that it's a busy time for
the kardashian-jenner squad twenty year
old Kylie has fans wondering if
boyfriend Travis Scott has put a ring on
it here's a snapchat video posted
driving to Kim's shower on Saturday
check out her left ring finger quite an
impressive diamond sparkler a source
confirmed to ET in September that the
couple is expecting their first child
together social media users are
speculating it's a girl after Kylie
posted several nods to the color pink
including holiday decor and a fresh
manicure
speaking of pink it was everywhere at
kim kardashian shower for baby number
three it's just a tea for three with
cherry blossom forest no surprise here
the 37 year old reality star went all
out with lavish tablescapes and cherry
blossoms sister Khloe Kardashian
attended along with close pals like
Malika and Khadijah hack and of course
Kim's four-year-old daughter North et
recently sat down with glam ma Kris
Jenner who gushed over Kim's expanding
family it's the best you know
they're the kids that bring such joy you
know and it makes everything worth it
when your kids the babies have babies
it's magic it really is
[Music]
you